[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro 2 ce
qui marque consacré aux travaux alors on
va parler évidemment du développement
des pistes cyclables on va parler de la
voirie on va pouvoir aller des travaux
sur la RN 10 à Trappes et puis des gares
parce qu'il se passe beaucoup de choses
dans les dans les gars à Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines et avant de retrouver
François lier qui est d'élégué en charge
de la voirie on va aller à la verrière
vous savez qu'il y a des travaux à la
gare de la verrière qui se termineront à
la fin de l'année et bien justement avec
Emmanuel Vega directeur des mobilités et
des grands travaux on fait le point sur
ce qui se passe à la gare de la verrière
[Musique]
pour l'ensemble des usagers sur la
verrière on aura un pôle avec une
intermodalité renforcée moderniser
beaucoup plus confortable et c'est toute
une impulsion
urbaine qui pourra s'amorcer ici sur ce
secteur stratégique de l'ouest de
l'agglomération
[Musique]
depuis début 2019 qui est la date de
mise en service du doublement du pont
Schuller les travaux se sont poursuivis
d'une manière intensive avec la
livraison de la gare routière qui
situait juste derrière moi en décembre
2022 au début de l'été on aura la
livraison du parking relais qui fait
environ 900 places
[Musique]
la mise en accessibilité de la rampe PMR
donc nord et sud avec l'adaptation du
passage souterrain pour la rentrée de
septembre le parvis de cette gare
également va être mise en service et
modernisée totalement pour la rentrée de
septembre et on aura en phase conclusive
la gare sud de la gare qui sera mise en
service pour novembre donc l'ensemble du
dispositif du Polgar sera complètement
finalisé et modernisé pour la fin de
cette année
[Musique]
ensoleillé bonjour bonjour vous êtes
adjoint au maire de Maurepas et vous
êtes en charge de la voirie pour la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin on vient de voir donc
c'est ces travaux à la gare de La
Verrière c'est important pour les
habitants de l'agglomération à Maurepas
notamment pas bien sûr c'est une gare on
l'appelle la gare de La Verrière mais
c'est aussi un peu la guerre de morsacle
comme on dit parfois tellement on est
proche c'est tellement de nombre de
mortasiens Latresne alors on l'attendait
beaucoup c'est vrai cette gare et on
attendait aussi beaucoup son parking et
qui va ouvrir le 1er juillet et surtout
le grand parvis qui va être devant qui
va être végétalisé et qui va porter un
peu de fraîcheur si je peux dire dans un
endroit qui en manquait ça fait partie
de ces grands projets de guerre et qu'il
faut moderniser c'est-à-dire les rendre
plus végétales un peu moins minéral
qu'avant et rendre plus accessibles pour
les handicapés ce qui n'était pas le cas
aujourd'hui et puis bien sûr favoriser
ce qu'on appelle dans notre jargon
l'intermodalité comme on dit c'est plus
pratique pour les bus c'est plus
pratique pour les vélos on aura un abri
vélo sécurisé voilà ce genre de choses
donc ça va changer un peu la vie des
usagers ah oui ça va changer la vie pour
être franc il y a aussi un vrai Paris
pour nous c'est ça va changer un peu
l'habitude ça a demandé à nourrir un de
changer un peu leurs habitudes
aujourd'hui ils étaient en partie aérien
gratuit là le parking va rester gratuit
pour ce coin passe Navigo mais il faudra
rentrer dans un parking qui illustre à
sécuriser donc normalement plus
confortable et plus fiable qu'avant quoi
d'accord c'était des travaux nécessaires
oui c'était vraiment des travaux
nécessaires mais il faut moderniser nos
gardes je vous parlais des cas de des
grands points d'accessibilité bien sûr
aux personnes handicapées
l'intermodalité pour les bus et pour les
vélos et puis cette végétalisation il
faut refaire des c'est pas du
centre-ville mais il faut refaire des
abords de guerre qui soit fréquentables
et qui donne envie de rester quoi je
dirais une petite buvette la prochaine
fois vous viendrez
alors puisqu'on parle de gars il y a
aussi d'autres travaux à Boutigny le
Bretonneux est en travaux pour
notamment la circulation autour de la
gare va être totalement
et puis il y a une gare qui est en
prévision alors là c'est pas bon tout de
suite c'est pour 2030 c'est la guerre de
Saint-Quentin s Saint-Quentin à côté de
à côté de Renault et c'est la gare qui
va accueillir quand elle sera au service
la ligne la fameuse ligne 18 la fameuse
ligne 18 c'est quand même pas tous les
jours qu'on crée une nouvelle ligne de
métro donc voilà c'est une ligne on sera
très très heureux d'y participer
effectivement ça va permettre de créer
une nouvelle guerre et ça raccroche bien
Saint-Quentin à l'ensemble de
l'agglomération parisienne donc ça a
vraiment facilité
d'être sur le parcours effectivement ça
va faciliter là aussi nombre de
déplacements puis on va en l'évoquer on
sait pas de quoi demain sera fait et on
sait en tout cas qu'il aura besoin de
transport en commun et qui a besoin
d'élargir cette espèce de couleur de
parisienne pour pas obligé de revenir
dans Paris à chaque fois qu'on va aller
au lit quoi et bien en fait le point sur
ces travaux avec Emmanuel Vega
[Musique]
la modernisation du pôle gare de
Montigny se poursuit avec notamment
l'objectif de donner une visibilité et
une accessibilité renforcée à cette gare
ces travaux seront particulièrement
perceptibles avec les travaux de
déconstruction de l'anneau rouge qui est
actuellement enclave la gare dans le
tissu urbain et qui permettront à terme
de complètement ouvrir la gare sur la
ville ces travaux ont débuté par le
curage et le désamantage depuis deux
mois vont se poursuivre tout le courant
de l'année 2023 pour arriver fin 2025 à
la réalisation de deux bâtiments
complètement modernes et qui donneront
un aspect beaucoup plus dynamique à tout
ce secteur
[Musique]
en parallèle sur le pôle gare la SNCF
poursuit ses travaux de mise en
accessibilité de modernisation de la
gare tous ces travaux seront finis en
janvier 2024 par la mise en service des
travées la torts qui permettront un
accès pour les
usagers de la gare au quotidien depuis
la passerelle rouge vers les quais et
donc l'accès au train d'une manière plus
générale c'est tout le renouveau de ce
secteur stratégique et fondamental avec
la polarité commerciale et tertiaire de
Saint-Quentin qui vont être totalement
modernisés dans les années qui viennent
avec notamment le très ambitieux projet
de modernisation de l'hypercentre ces
travaux vont débuter fin 2024 avec
l'avenue du centre et la place Pompidou
et c'est l'ensemble finalement de ce
secteur hyper simple qui dans les années
à venir vont totalement se moderniser
pour donner une attractivité renforcée
au territoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le métro de la ligne 18 dont la gare va
être localisée à proximité du
Technocentre à Guyancourt devient
aujourd'hui une certitude l'ensemble du
dispositif sera livré en 2030 et c'est
un enjeu très important notamment pour
les entreprises du territoire qui
attendaient ce projet majeur et
structurant
[Musique]
il va relier Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines au Plateau de
Saclay sur 35 km avec une infrastructure
qui va être structurée par digares c'est
Bigard vont permettre de relier 200.000
emplois et 65000 étudiants c'est un une
infrastructure qui finalement nous
insère dans la dynamique du Grand Paris
qui y est une révolution en matière de
transport en commun sur l'ensemble de la
région Île-de-France c'est également un
projet important en termes urbain
puisque c'est toute une dynamique
urbaine qui va s'installer autour du
métro et notamment avec Guyancourt qu'il
y aura le développement d'une ZAC la ZAC
des savoirs qui va métamorphoser
également tout secteurs et qui va
s'accompagner d'un développement
économique fort
[Musique]
le Grand Paris Express la convient de
voir qui reliera 50 ans en 2030 c'est
évidemment une évolution majeure ah oui
c'est même une chance pour notre
agglomération alors on était bien sûr
faisait partie de la région parisienne
on est associé à Paris mais c'est vrai
que ça nous donne des un complément à
dire de liaison de
intercommunications qui vont être très
précieuses pour nous pour le
développement économique qui puisse
sociale de Saint-Quentin oui alors nous
trouvons au pied de la colline
Bellancourt
de grandes épreuves de l'Île-de-France
absolument combien de mètres 231 mètres
c'est pas les Alpes
de VTT aux JO donc ça c'est évidemment
important c'est une grande fierté
mais le vélo il n'y a pas que les
champions il y a aussi les cyclistes et
là il y a beaucoup d'efforts qui sont
faits sur eux
notamment dans ce dans ce périmètre
d'ailleurs nous sommes ici d'ailleurs
sur une piste cyclable qui est en train
d'être rénovée comme vous voyez la
couche de roulement vient d'être faite
signalisation quand même la signalétique
à mettre en place mais voilà
effectivement 50 ans en Yvelines pour
donner un ordre de grandeur c'est plus
de 430 km d'itinéraire cyclable j'ai pas
de piste cyclable aujourd'hui mais
d'itinéraire qui peuvent être empruntés
par les vélos et ben notre ambition
c'est ça s'est transformé les
itinéraires parfois pas toujours très
fréquentable par des pistes comme
celle-là mais qui sont vraiment
quasiment des voies vertes donc très
larges et permettant de favoriser les
vélos les piétons les trottinettes
est-ce que vous parlez des yeux
évidemment est-ce que justement le le
les yeux obligé à repenser un peu le le
schéma des pistes cyclables sur la sur
l'agglomération et dans cette danse
voilà notamment
c'est vrai que le vélo était déjà une
priorité et puis un objet s enfin une
ambition assez importante pour
Saint-Quentin depuis des années
déjà beaucoup investi là-dessus je dis
on est quand même à 430 km d'itinéraire
ce qui n'est pas rien mais c'est vrai
qu'on est à peut-être à 3% modalités
donc c'est pas encore énorme en
fréquentation et on avait l'objectif de
passer à 8 % dans les années qui
viennent donc on va voilà donc on se
développe pour ça on a un projet
ambitieux de donc je vous dis de
transformer en piscine là vraiment
toutes les itinéraires on a un budget
depuis 30 millions d'euros
d'investissement de gros investissements
alors ce qu'on a changé en perspective
des JO mais c'est qu'on a priorisé
certaines pistes comme celle-là et qui
émèneront directement au point au point
de rassemblement des JO pour que les
gens mais en même temps on a fait
attention à faire un peu de rénovation
dans l'ensemble des douze communes pour
que tout le monde pour embarquer comme
on dit un maximum de personnes et faire
en sorte qu'un maximum de 50 ninois et
puis finalement s'habituer à prendre le
vélo et découvrir que c'est aussi bien
que la voiture surtout par ses
températures bon on va faire le point
avec quelqu'un que vous connaissez bien
qui est violentes Philibert qui est en
charge des opérations pour le pour les
vélos et qui va faire le point justement
sur les travaux sur les pistes cyclables
qui auront lieu cet été
[Musique]
le déploiement du schéma directeur
cyclable communautaire va se dérouler
jusqu'aux JO en plusieurs étapes la
première étape c'est nos cinq chantiers
cet été la suite ça va être en
enchaînement au cours de l'automne
jusqu'au printemps prochain ou sur
différents sites de l'agglomération on
va réaliser les morceaux manquants des
lignes structurantes pour la desserte
des sites des JO
[Musique]
donc cet été on intervient sur 5 Sites
le premier à Élancourt le long du RD 58
pour la desserte entre autres de la
colline
un second un plaisir avenue du 19 mars
62 un autre la voie verte de l'île de
loisirs sur lequel nous nous trouvons
actuellement un autre chantier à
Maurepas Coignières qui est d'une voie
verte entre la rue des Frères Lumière et
le chemin du Moulin à vent car un
dernier chantier un magnilait hameaux le
long de la route de Châteaufort
[Musique]
ce que j'aime dans mon travail c'est la
réalisation d'aménagement d'espace qui
vont être utilisés par plein d'usagers
qui trouveront leur place et leur compte
et aujourd'hui c'est réalisations
prennent en compte à la fois toutes les
problèmes écologiques et à la fois le
partage de l'espace avec les modes
actifs et donc le déploiement du schéma
directeur pour moi c'est ça c'est
redonner de la place en mode actifs leur
redonner une place efficace sécurisée et
continue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment c'est des travaux sur la RN 10
et qui ont commencé à trappe notamment
alors c'est c'est vraiment un serpent de
mer c'est vraiment un projet qui est
rentré maintenant dans sa phase de
réalisation importante un très gros
projet au niveau de 50 ans Yvelines
peut-il s'agit de faire un enfouissement
de la N10 en fluide nationale vous
imaginez bien la complexité de ce genre
de travaux
alors en plus derrière l'enfouissement
on va pas être la possibilité de créer
un vrai plateau urbain qui va permettre
de mettre fin à cette cicatrice urbaine
qui coupait la ville de trap en 2 et qui
était quand même préjudiciaire pour tous
les habitants on espère bien que ça
pourra se prolonger du côté de malmedone
donc entre la verrière et Maurepas un
petit peu plus loin sur l'indice avec le
même type d'opération un enfouissement
au niveau de la N10 pour permettre un
pont au dessus et permettre de relier à
la gare de La Verrière qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure au quartier de la même me donne
si ça prend du temps c'est parce qu'il y
a beaucoup d'acteurs dans ce genre de
projets c'est clairement des
financements c'est important et ça va de
l'État de la Région le Département
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines les communes
et puis vous imaginez bien la logistique
pour organiser tout ça donc
effectivement c'est d'être très
important je vous propose de regarder un
sujet tout en images qui nous explique
justement ceux que sont sur les travaux
sur la RN 10 à Trappes
[Musique]
voilà des importants de travaux de la RN
10 François liais alors on dit beaucoup
que de Saint-Quentin c'est un territoire
d'innovation innover c'est aussi prévoir
mais parfois on se dit c'est absolument
impossible maintenant de prévoir le
monde de ton constant changement
climatique des énormes changements
l'intelligence artificielle tout ce qui
vient comment on fait comment on fait
alors pour essayer de ne pas se tromper
ça c'est une bonne question en tout cas
il faut prendre des risques et en
matière si en matière de mobilité ben on
sait l'importance du transport en commun
c'est l'importance de l'Inter modalité
la voirie on sait l'importance de
travailler sur la qualité de la voirie
OK et on fait en sorte d'innover comme
vous voyez vous l'avez rappelé
Saint-Quentin c'est un territoire
d'innovation que c'est bien ça notre
objectif notre ambition c'est une
continuer innover que pour être prêt
pour les rendez-vous de demain
à tous ceux qui nous regardez tous les
habitants puisque finalement tous ces
travaux qui vont avoir lieu bon
améliorer leur vie c'est bien le respect
bel été à tous merci beaucoup Françoise
merci
[Musique]